hello welcome to the Google cloud career
readiness program Google cloud has
developed a cloud engineer career
readiness path for students and faculty
in higher education let's take a look at
the cloud landscape and learn more about
the associate cloud engineer track
enterprises are migrating to the cloud
and building new applications on the
cloud leading industry research
indicates that a shift to cloud will
affect more than one trillion dollars in
IT spending adoption of cloud native
applications will double by 2020 this
accelerated move towards cloud has
created a tremendous demand for
qualified professionals who are
proficient in cloud technologies
traditional roles are evolving in a
cloud first world for example an app
developer or data analyst needs new
skills to succeed with cloud
technologies new roles related to DevOps
data science and machine learning are
emerging you can kick start your career
in cloud related career paths
Google's leading-edge Enterprise ready
curriculum and learning resources can
help you achieve industry recognized
associate cloud engineer certification
the associate cloud engineer track
provides training free of charge to
prepare for the associate cloud engineer
certification exam this track includes
access to the architecting with Google
cloud platform specialization on
Coursera this on-demand training
includes six in-depth courses with
videos hands-on labs and quizzes
hands-on experience is crucial for
success with the associate cloud
engineer certification exam you'll
receive credits to complete self-paced
labs on the quick labs platform free of
charge this training puts you on the
path to success for achieving the
associate cloud engineer certification
based on course completion timelines and
other criteria
receive a 50% discount on the
certification exam familiarity with the
following topics is helpful for success
with the associate cloud engineer track
operating systems file systems the IP
networking stack how web browsers and
web servers communicate databases
programming working with Linux at the
command-line and editing text files from
the Linux command line to participate in
this track you'll need a laptop or
desktop with the latest versions of any
popular web browser the Google Chrome
browser is recommended robust internet
connection to access Google cloud
platform console is required let's look
at the training in a bit more detail the
associate cloud engineer track has two
main training components the
architecting with Google cloud platform
specialization on Coursera covers topics
related to exploring and deploying
solution elements including
infrastructure components such as
networks systems and application
services the cloud architecture quest on
the quick labs platform is a set of
hands-on labs that provide practice on
topics and services that appear in the
associate cloud engineer certification
exam it's highly recommended that you
complete additional labs as well the
training you receive in the associate
cloud engineer track provides a solid
foundation for preparing to take this
certification exam however the training
does not teach exactly what you will
need to pass a test practical hands-on
experience is also needed make sure to
get hands-on experience by practicing
with the suggested labs and quick labs
and to review product documentation
you'll learn a course completion
certificate from Google cloud upon
completing the Coursera specialization
successfully success in the Associate
cloud engineer certification exam
enables you to them
straight to potential employers that you
have the skills necessary to succeed in
roles that require proficiency in cloud
technologies the associate cloud
engineer track must be completed in 16
weeks this slide shows a suggested
timeline complete architecting with
Google cloud platform specialization
within the first nine weeks complete
cloud architecture quest and other
hands-on labs by week 16 your access to
Coursera will expire at the end of 16
weeks practice for the certification
exam and complete the exam before the
voucher expiration date remember you can
race ahead of the suggested timeline
let's now take a quick look at the
Student Resource Center the Student
Resource Center includes FA cues as well
as study jam materials for extra
practice to clarify study jams are
essentially workshops if you're not able
to meet other students in a workshop
setting you can work through the study
jam materials on your own as well if you
have questions about the associate cloud
engineer track check the FAQ and the
support section for information happy
learning